[Music]
in february 2022
beijing will host the winter olympics
the chinese communist party will use
those games as a grand propaganda
spectacle to boost its domestic
legitimacy
and to boast of china's inexorable rise
on the international scene
or so xi jinping hopes given the ongoing
human rights abuses in china the party's
culpability for the kovit-19 pandemic
and its obvious inability to guarantee
the safety and well-being of olympic
athletes
an international effort to move cancel
or boycott the beijing games is in order
the 2022 winter olympic games will take
place just months before the 20th
national congress of the chinese
communist party
a cancellation or significant boycott of
the olympics might further weaken xi
jinping
in ways that make a leadership challenge
however remote that possibility
somewhat more likely even if a boycott
or cancellation fails to put significant
pressure on she
absenting ourselves from the 2022 games
is the right thing to do
the alternative is to send team usa to
beijing and
in so doing choose complicity in china's
worst abuses
do you think the united states should
boycott the 2022 winter olympics
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei